in the heart of a township on the
outskirts of johannesburg
people seized and stole at will as they
have done
for the past few days and there is
little
or no fear of the authorities here
turmoil and anarchy have gripped some of
south africa's largest cities
and the government has had to respond
with armed police
and members of the military but the
looters and the rioters
are fleet of foot and rubber bullets do
not seem to scare them
[Applause]
we followed the authorities down a local
thoroughfare
but they only managed to catch one man
before they handed the area back
to the troublemakers
later we found the south african police
minister
becky kelly doing a walkabout through
the rubble
but he didn't want to answer our
questions minister do you have the
situation here under control
you have the situation here under
control
it doesn't look like it
the unrest began after the country's
former president
jacob zuma was arrested but a series of
protests
have grown into something far more
troubling
here on an estate near durban residents
filled their
arms with televisions microwaves and
bikes
plundered from a distribution center
in johannesburg shops and businesses
have been targeted
or destroyed despite the efforts of the
police
although they caught up with looters at
this supermarket
as they battled to escape through the
back
in a place called tembisa the shops and
the post office
have been set alight all of the shops in
this uh
in this plaza have been looted but
they're also destroying them as well
setting fire individual shops they must
have
there must be half a dozen now gone up
in flames but they're still here picking
through
the ruins you can hear them in this shop
you can see them up on the counter
they don't like being filmed i think we
should go
a fight back of sorts has begun to
emerge
as community groups seek to save the
businesses that provide them with jobs
but they can't count on the authorities
and the looters feel
no sense of self-restraint john sparks
sky news in johannesburg